[Musik]
die maschine ist künftig eine boeing 737
ryanair aber nur mit diesem flugzeugtyp
mit eingebauter treppe das spart
bodenpersonal und mit dem prinzip kosten
drücken hat ryanair den europäischen
markt aufgemischt
an bord der maschine aus dublin
vorstandsmitglieder von ryanair
sie wissen dass der flughafen berlin
schönefeld aus allen nähten platzt
trotzdem wollen sie ihr geschäft in der
deutschen hauptstadt ausbauen
ich will wissen ob es stimmt dass sie
flüge für unter zehn euro anbieten
jahrmarkt für 99 90 von ihr nach belfast
liegen mit stolz mit steuern was
verdienen sie damit nichts sie wollen
nichts verdient naja wenn man 117
millionen passagiere auf 1800 toten hat
ver.di man nicht mit jedem kunden der
marketingvorstand kenny jacob's ist für
zwei tage in berlin kommt aber nur mit
handgepäck wollen sie sich nicht
umziehen in zwei tagen
ich gebe eine pressekonferenz ein
anderer richter und werde von der hüfte
aufwärts offiziell aussehen und untenrum
habe es bequem
sie sollten erst mal sehen wo wir heute
nacht absteigen
was wird das seien 5 euro 99 mit
frühstück und steuern
nein es kostet 79 euro aber es ist ein
posten
nein hier übernachtet er nicht dieses
hotel ist eine der teuersten adressen
berlins er hat hier für ein paar stunden
einen saal gemietet
irgendwie passt das nicht weiß auch
keine jobs
2017 bereits 19 neue roten von berlin
aus fliegen die meisten maschinen hat
die fluggesellschaft in großbritannien
stationiert aber das dürfte sich bald
ändern
berlin und deutschland profitieren vom
drag city herrschaft in großbritannien
ein gefühl der unsicherheit
das ist ein sehr großer markt für
fluglinien aber in den nächsten jahren
werden wir weniger in großbritannien
investieren
schon jetzt liegen 16 millionen berlin
besucher mit ryanair
das will die fluggesellschaft im
nächsten jahr mehr als verdreifacht
ich frage kennen jacob's warum
ausgerechnet deutschland und an welche
kunden herzlich beendet wenn du ein
schickimicki deutscher bist mit einem
haufen geld bist du kein typischer
ryanair kunde und was wird den
mitarbeitern am schalter bekommen die
den mindestlohn
sie bekommen mehr als den mindestlohn in
berlin arbeiten indirekt rund 450
menschen für uns sie bekommen ein sehr
gutes gehalt
denn wäre das nicht so würden sie ganz
einfach für eine andere fluglinie
arbeiten oder für einen anderen
flughafen um bei den löhnen zu sparen
arbeitet ryanair mit subunternehmern
dafür werden sie von europäischen
gewerkschaften oft kritisiert aber die
ihren weisen alle vorwürfe weit von sich
wie gelingt es der fluggesellschaft dann
so günstige tickets zu verkaufen wo auch
immer es geht an den flughäfen oder beim
marketing oder beim kerosinpreis überall
versuchen wir die kosten zu gering wie
möglich zu halten
[Musik]
der alte berliner flughafen schönefeld
soll extra für die ihren erweitert
werden und selbst dann auch in betrieb
bleiben wenn gleich nebenan endlich der
neue großflughafen ber eröffnet aber der
wird und wird nicht fertig dieser
terminal am flughafen berlin-schönefeld
funktioniert sehr gut für uns und auch
in der neue b eröffnet wird er ja schon
zu klein sein
das ist eine gute nachricht und es zeigt
dass immer mehr menschen nach berlin
wollen
aber der wird vermutlich nicht als die
beste deutsche ingenieursleistung die
geschichte eingehen
die touristen stört das nicht
die wollen einfach günstig liegen auch
wenn sie dafür auf komfort verzichten
darauf setzt kenny goss nächstes jahr
will ryanair 5,4 millionen menschen nach
berlin bringen